it breaks my heart to say that two days
before Christmas Dax died suddenly the
news was a gut punch the cause of death
of death contrary to what ABC News
executive Kim Godwin said last month the
ABC News producer did not die from a
heart attack on December 23rd Dax was as
full of life as anybody I've ever known
his time on Earth was too short but he
lived like every moment counted
ET has confirmed that Dax choked to
death because he was intoxicated while
out to dinner with his wife and friends
at Bobby Van's Steakhouse
a spokesperson for the New York City
chief medical examiner tells E.T that
his official cause of death was asphyxia
due to obstruction of Airway by food
bolus complicating acute alcohol
intoxication he was 37 years old
just last month Godwin released a
statement addressing dax's death at the
time his cause of death was suspected to
be something different it's with a heavy
heart and great sadness that we share
that our friend and colleague Dax Tierra
passed away suddenly of a heart attack
the TV exec added that as the executive
producer of this week with George
Stephanopoulos dax's energy passion and
love for that show ABC News and you
shined every Sunday morning Dax was
passionate about his work and even more
so about his family
speaking to a group of ABC News
colleagues just last month he noted the
big changes in his life since he started
to work at ABC in my time at ABC I've
gotten married I've had two children One
turns five months tomorrow One turns two
today so I'm gonna bolt out to try to
blow out the candles shortly after the
tragedy dax's wife Veronica was arrested
and booked on two counts of acting in a
manner injurious to a child accused of
leaving their two-year-old and
five-month-old daughters alone at a
hotel in the hours leading up to his
sudden death in a statement shared with
E.T the mom of two said she made a poor
decision explaining that when Dax
collapsed she accompanied him in an
ambulance to the hospital and asked a
close friend and her parents to go to
her children's hotel room but when they
arrived she says the hotel wouldn't
allow them in and instead call the
police
Veronica added that they had two cameras
on the kids while they slept and she
monitored them closely while she was
away from them our family has suffered a
terrible tragedy I respectfully ask for
privacy while my children and I mourn
dax's death
following his death ABC News paid
tribute to Dax with an emotional segment
pointing out the TV producers deep love
for his wife and children the love of
dax's life was his wife Veronica and
their two children Sophia and Ella it
was with great pride that Dax brought
Sophia and Ella to this week in
September he was happy living the life
of his dreams Ella and Sophia I want you
to know your father was a great talent
but more importantly he was a good man
and he loved the two of you and your
mother more than anything in the world
[Music]